uh
chairman we're live thank you sonya
good morning members and a warm welcome
to this
fun forum meeting and also i would like
to extend
a warm welcome to any members of the
public that are viewing this
on rockford council's youtube channel
i would like to open by making a number
of
comments
the last forum met on the 27th of
january 2020
it seems that the recent rainfall has
particularly
provoked the urgency for another meeting
um and uh hence we are meeting today
but i have to say that the circumstances
in which
we meet are not ideal
they are not ideal because i
passionately believe
that there should be a public
opportunity for interaction with members
and the various agencies so that there
can be
appropriate dialogue with everyone
and so that we can address this in a
open and transparent way unfortunately
um the system that we are using is
dictated by
uh zoom and the youtube channel ideally
i would have liked this to have been a
totally
open uh meeting so that it was um
a uh opportunity to see members of
the public who wish to join us and have
dialogue so uh i as chairman would like
to apologize that that
can't happen um partly through the
difficulties of the present time of
having media
these these virtual meetings but what i
would like to say
at the outset is i've actually called
for a traditional
flood forum meeting to take place in the
autumn
to hopefully take place in the
conventional way in which we would meet
so i see this as a best fit
meeting and i look forward to
the return of proper uh physical
meetings
hopefully in the autumn and that meeting
will pick up
particularly on issues that are raised
today
and give people to have the opportunity
to have a
proper dialogue
now the way i intend to
handle today is to go through the formal
agenda
but i certainly want to ensure that we
have plenty of time
to deal with questions and current
issues
rather than spending an awful lot of
time on historical issues
which i gather are historical because
they've appeared on the agenda
or they've appeared on the notes for on
previous occasions and on many occasions
so i do actually want to ensure that we
devote
most of our time today to the live
issues that have been raised
so by way of introductory comments
i think that's as far as i want to go um
first of all looking around the screen i
can't see any people that were on the
list to attend
not being here sonia but are you aware
of any apologies
no i'm not aware of any apologies
chairman okay thank you very much indeed
and now the notes of the meeting of the
20th century
chairman sorry to interrupt um i know
it's not on the agenda but i do
need feel that i need to declare a
couple of points of interest
in interest with regards to to the
agenda and some of the questions that
have
come up later so sorry for interrupting
you
absolutely no problem council stepped
over did you want to make
those points now that might be an
approach if i
if i make check um obviously i need to
declare
interest as uh both parish and
county councillor for the area of
barling but most importantly
with regards to the matter of barling
creek i do need to declare that one of
the
tributes that run into bali creek
actually runs through my garden
so i do have a particular interest there
thank you
thank you councillor um and uh are there
any other members that wish to
record similar sort of comments under
what would be known as
declarations councillor gooding
i would just like to declare that i'm a
ward councillor
in hawkward west and i'm hoping to be
covering
the the problem in rectory road which is
part of my wall thank you
thank you councillor judy gooding uh
councillor michael hoy
um yes thank you chairman i just declare
it interesting it should be on the
agenda i think councilwood
said he'd put it on there but the um
there's an issue of
um flooding around the um barrett david
wilson home site in holbridge
which i back on to thank you okay lovely
thank you council
boy um look this is going to be a
meeting with a bit of a difference but
i do not want to preclude any items so
can you make sure that during the course
of the next uh
um hour or two uh you make sure that it
is brought into the uh
meeting agenda if it gets overlooked for
any reason i'm sure you will counsel
ahoy
i think you're speaking that you're
you're on mute
sorry i wasn't speaking but yes i will
thank you okay all right thank you very
much indeed
um okay look what i think we'll do
is we will go through the notes now
first of all
members uh are they generally generally
an accurate record i wasn't here
i wasn't sharing this time last year um
but i'm dependent on
you telling me councilman first and you
have your hand up
thank you very much chairman um like
yourself i wasn't present at the
last um forum meeting um but hopefully
um councillors who were present can um
confirm this um on page four
it refers to barling creek kimberley
road ditch
there's a strange comment at the end
which says remove
so um i don't know why anybody would
have put remove
as there's been an ongoing issue since
2014 which has not been resolved
perhaps somebody who was present can
advise thank you
thank you councilman person look on
points of
accuracy i'm really asking if they are
an accurate record
in terms of the notes themselves in
terms of the matters arising
we'll come to those in a moment but um
our
people people content that they are a uh
uh accurate record
of notes of the last meeting uh i'm
seeing two
hands up um jeff stacy
um you want to come in
yes sorry i just wanted to come in on
the apologies side of things we have had
an apology from
richard baronovsky from essex county
council highways
but he has provided me with with an
update which i'll do on his behalf
okay thanks very much indeed jeff i was
going to come to the attendees in in a
while but uh thank you for that uh
thank you um right council spectre you
have your hand up
yes chairman it's with reference to as
you go through the notes i've got a
couple of
points to uh uh just to clarify okay
thank you i am really just taking points
is it an accurate record of the notes
would you
please raise your blue hand and there
are two blue hands raised at the moment
but will you please raise your blue hand
to indicate your
satisfaction with the notes
all right council western you haven't
indicated
as i wasn't at the last meeting uh
chairman i wasn't too sure whether i
should agree okay
all right now that's totally
understandable right okay perhaps i hope
to do it in a different way
and say for those people that were at
the last meeting
um if you are unhappy with any aspect of
the notes can you please raise your hand
uh i'll do it in a slightly different
way so so one way or another we'll get
approval of these notes
right okay well i'm not seeing any
raised hands so i will take it that
people are generally happy that those
notes represent a fair record of the
last meeting
thank you now moving on to uh items
uh from those last notes the way i
intend to
deal with this is at this stage asked
jeff stacy to
tell me exactly who is here from our uh
partner agencies if you could just run
through you've already
made the point about um
essex county council highways but do you
want to just tell us who's
who's here please jeff
yep certainly we've got uh dave chapman
from essex county council
roger webster from uh
environment agency and
i did spot another visitor who seems to
have disappeared
mark lloyd yes he's there
i can see him all right and uh
mark lloyd from england water
thank you very much chairman thank you
very much
and now coming back to um
essex county council highways and you
made reference
earlier to richard baranovsky uh not
being here
why have we not got representation from
essex county highways
uh yes fisher was informed from
sort of higher up the within essex
county council
and that there wasn't the capacity for
him to be able to attend
uh local meetings such as this
okay um right okay i see dave chapman's
hand up yeah just uh sorry thanks chair
uh just on
um on attendance uh i i don't know
whether or not angling water were
was sent the invite directly um but i
was contacted by them
uh last week i actually forwarded the
invite to
two officers from anglian water i know
that they're not on the meeting but i
just wanted to raise that as a
maybe if they were missed off the
original list i don't know but i have
invited them
and i don't know whether or not they've
um shared with anybody that they can or
can't make it but i thought i just
raised that
but so i may be getting confused here
but i thought mark lloyd
represented anglia walter that's correct
i'm here
oh brilliant okay i passed over to
jonathan and brett so
i didn't recognize the name sorry mark
no problem
okay good well that's anglian water but
i have to come back to essex county
council and ask
why are essex county council highways
not here
okay clearly um no answer on that
councillor williams you have your hand
up
yeah thank you chairman i'm very very
disappointed as i'm fellow hold of
the environment and place i'm very
disappointed that we're in
essex county council highways are not
represented perhaps we could ask our
county um councillors to to bring
pressure that uh
they do attend next time thank you okay
thank you for that council williams um
council western
uh yes thanks chairman um i i'm going to
apologize for essex county council
highways because i know that um lee is
up to his eyes
very very busy but i will take this on
board i'm sure with mark
mike stetto and june lovely to make sure
that
um someone like um kevin bentley
or his uh um
his advice will be at the next meeting
sorry
um chairman uh thank you very much
indeed councillor weston
um and uh um thank you for that support
and i'm sure
along with your colleague councillor
stepco but your other
colleagues who aren't necessarily here
county colleagues
you will make the strongest
representation and i wish it to be
recorded that um
i think it is a grave discourtesy
that essex county council highways are
not here
part of the reason why we have this
forum is to
bring the various agencies together so
that we can
actually see what is going on
one of the frustrations of members of
the public
is that they get bounced around various
authorities
and they get totally frustrated with
people
pushing it onto another area and whilst
rochford district council has no
statutory responsible
responsibility for flooding i do believe
it has a responsibility to pull partners
together
in this type of forum so that we can
actually
address some of the concerns within our
district
and i do not think it is good enough for
people just to arbitrarily decide
whether they will or whether they won't
attend the meeting
so i want all pressure brought to bear
from an officer perspective
and certainly from a council perspective
to say that when we invite partners
it is because we need them to be
accountable for the services that
they're providing
and it is not at their discretion
whether or not they wish to attend
they are required to attend having made
that point i'll move to councilman
mcpherson
thank you chairman um wholeheartedly
agree with your comments
um to add to um councillor williams
suggestion that they are strongly
encouraged to come to future
meetings i would go one step further and
ask our county councillors who are
present to make sure any questions that
are raised
today that are under the responsibility
of essex county highways to answer
that they respond within a timely period
is that okay thank you very much indeed
councilman mcpherson councillor stepped
out
yeah thank you two points uh one yes i
do believe richard has responded to the
questions that were sent to him i do
believe that's the case
uh and secondly i don't see anybody from
the environmental
agency uh was anybody invited from the
environmental agency
i'm here yes roger webster i think roger
webster was introduced to us at the
start and i will
um give them their great moments of fame
in a while but
uh but thank you roger for being here
thank you mark for being here uh and
also
my apologies chair i didn't recognize
the name thank you to
uh dave chapman so uh whilst deploying
the fact that some people
that should be here aren't i also
welcome uh
colleagues and they'll have their uh
moment to talk in a moment
um council of westland you wish to speak
again
yes thank you sir i don't um i take on
board what councilman firstner says but
can i just reiterate
that all county councils are coming up
for elections this year
including myself my june etc um
so we will go back and ask questions but
please
be bear with us because we've got a big
fight on our hands and some of us have
got two seats
to fight so i will take that on board
councilman and i'm sure councilman mike
stepped so we'll do exactly the same
okay right thank you very much indeed
right i'm going to take the notes
um and we're now under the um
matters arising and and i'm going to
ask the various partner agencies to go
through
their section and give any comments in
particular to
the notes and if i could ask those
updates to be reasonably brief please
because
i don't want us to spend all morning
talking about the notes i do want to get
on to the questions
reasonably soon but if i could
ask i think it's dave chapman if you
could take us through the first
uh section in relation to the notes of
the meeting and any comments that you
wish to make
and then i'll take questions from any
members following that
is there a copy of the notes on this can
we put a copy of the notes on the screen
or
is there a copy of the notes attached to
the agenda that i can
refer to um
could you give me a moment and i'll
locate them
experiment just while we're waiting for
uh for sonia
and can i answer a couple of points that
have already been raided that raised
with regards to the notes
certainly council stepped up first of
all with regards to
uh the item on page four barlene creek
uh the original reference there to was
to the
with regards to the sluice gate which
has been replaced by
um the environmental agency uh some time
ago now and that was the reason that it
was
uh looked to be removed because it was
referenced to the sluice gate
not any other particular problem at the
time but i was going to ask that the
comment to have it
the item removed is removed
and because there is ongoing situation
secondly
as well on page six with regards to
sutton road
uh what i've referred to as in the past
the canal by the side of
uh purdey's there is still an ongoing
situation
there with water having an outlet
from the ditch that was required to be
dug by
as its county council um and that is
still an ongoing situation so
that very much to be continue on the uh
on the agendas okay thank you very much
indeed council staffer very difficult to
pursue points under the heading of essex
county council highways
if they're not actually bothered to
attend the meeting um
on that particular point chairman i am
pursuing that offline from this meeting
that is uh something i'm dealing with as
a separation
no that's that's that's great news and
thank you for that but uh
i make the point that it is actually
under the uh
council highways section and um they can
hardly pick it up as an action to work
with you if they're not even here so
i'll just make that point now are we
going to make progress on these uh
on these notes i think i found the
agenda notes
chair if you'd like me just to read
through those updates if that's okay
well i just like updates please really
yeah sure so
um the first one the first one from
essex county council flood team is the
work that we're doing with rochford dc
on uh rural and um
we've had conversations with marcus
hooton and and 106 money that
is available to be spent there um the
uh the latest is that it's sitting with
marcus to make sure that he's
covered all aspects of where that money
can or cannot be spent and how much
that's likely to be
before he then makes a decision on which
ones he takes forward
so myself and roger and some other
partners have been involved with marcus
about what we can do going forward and
we just waiting for marcus to make the
decision on where that money is to be
spent
okay so have we got a timeline as to
when we think that's likely to happen uh
the latest i had unless roger's got
something
different i think mark marcus mentioned
he was looking sort of august september
time this year
okay well if we recall that in the um
in the uh notes that there's you know i
would like some clear
um timelines when some of these actions
are going to be completed otherwise they
just drift on and i'm sure you would
agree with me um councillor stanley you
want to come in at that point
if i may chairman uh just to give you an
update
um uh uh i've arranged
with uh marcus to have a walkthrough
with the the relevant agencies on
roarie it's not a question of uh where
the money's going to be spent it's a
question of looking at
the area and and taking in
what is happening and and so on so i
would suggest that
uh i've already spoke to marcus on when
they when everybody is available to have
a walkthrough
and i'm sure he will update you
accordingly
council stanley that's very helpful
thank you very much um
what i'm keen is that these things do
get
progressed um rather than sit on a uh
on a um you know without any clear
action so
uh dave right if you want to make
progress in your
your section please sure uh the second
second
uh item that i had was the um magnolia
park this is all linked into
what we would call the action critical
training area
and um what we've had what we did there
originally we split that into two phases
as recorded at the last meeting phase
one is now not going to happen
but phase two is hopefully going to
progress later on this year it's linked
with development
um and law homes which i think is
currently going through the planning
process
um the delivery of that scheme is
reliant on the application being
approved because the land that we are
going to deliver that flood scheme on
is actually part of the land that's
being developed um from raw homes and
their application
um so with the at the moment the
indicative program is that they will be
on site
if the application is approved in
september this year
so that's where we are with uh the the
flooding in washington
related to the magnolia park horizon
okay thank you
um and then the last bit is just
if i may just take councillor gooding as
we go through in case it belongs to that
particular item councilman
yes sorry it was related to that item i
i was just trying to find
uh sorry i don't know the background
because i haven't been on the flood
forum before
um but the how the bloor homes
area how that affects magnolia park
and if you can explain please yes
so the history was that the the flooding
in ashland was split into two phases so
phase one was the ashland
apartment you were at the magnolia
partner you referred to
that was looked at separately
unfortunately there was no scheme that
was financially viable to be able to be
delivered there as well why that phase
was never taken forward
into construction the second phase which
is north of rochester garden way
is the element that's then linked to the
law homes application for
new houses on that side thank you very
much indeed for that clarification dave
right moving on
um i think it's the last item that i
have it's just a capital flood program
update
um so where we are we're in the sixth
year of our
capital flood programme um we've got
funding assured for
2021 22 um which is great news so we're
going to be continuing the work
we've been doing over the last six years
into next financial year
there is a provisional earmarked value
that takes the capital flood program as
it currently stands up to the year 2425
now year on year we'll have to bid and
provide a business case to allow that
funding to be
spent and where that funding will be
spent but at the moment
provisional sums have been recorded and
we've made a request up to the year
2425.
just as a side issue it's it's something
completely separate
to the flood program that has been
running for the six years
is that essex county council along with
a number of partners
made a bid to the innovation fund and
that is a separate pot of money
that if successful will run from 2021 to
2027.
now um we should hear whether or not
that financial
uh application has been successful in
april
and then we will then refine that
business case and then
submit to to draw down that money if we
are indeed successful later on this
financial year
we're just still waiting to see or hear
whether or not we've been successful
with an actual application okay thank
you
councillor stanley
thank you chairman um could i ask the
question then uh
how much of the funding that is uh
at this moment in time available where
is it going to be spent
in uh the rochester area especially
um where we have these difficulties that
we have at the moment
so the innovation bid itself was uh
concentrating on the
the river coal and the river black water
catchments um whereas
essex county council have identified
that
as part of their essex climate action
commission focus areas
um so we predominantly looked at what we
can do to work within those two river
catchments to provide
betterments not only in flood risk but
coastal and main river but also
help tackle the the uh challenges that
are coming out of the essex climate
action commission so that's where we
predominantly focused our efforts
but also there was a value of what that
bid
could be up to uh it was up to six
million pound potentially for each
scheme um for each bid and our bid
actually was it was virtually at seven
and a half million pounds so we had to
be very ruthless in
the areas in which we could concentrate
any potential funding because at the
moment it's only potential funding
and unfortunately with the criteria that
we were looking at for coal and river
river coal and river black water
catchments the improvements that were
provisionally put forward
for roarworth didn't make the
application itself that we submitted in
january unfortunately
thank you for that
thank you thank you chairman i i just uh
wonder just when um any money will be
available
for rayleigh roarie and rochford
um because it's it it doesn't seem as
though there is
anything that's moving towards helping
the area that we all live in and rather
than i know there are
others that live near the black water
and so on but
um a distribution of uh funds
wouldn't wouldn't go and miss in this
area i'm sure you'll agree with me
uh chairman okay council standing a
point well made
i don't want us to deflect from dealing
with the notes but i'm sure that davey's
taking that back and other members have
noted the uh
the point are quite well made and i
don't agree with you and
can i just take the rest of the section
and pages two pages three pages four
and ask members if there's any further
points that you wish to raise
uh specifically related to any of the
points uh on those pages
council award you have your hand up
yes thank you chairman yeah it's just on
page three
first item noble's green ditch which is
now been
attributed i believe to the river roach
on maps
by uh angelina walter um
i see that it's removed from agenda but
i would just like people to note uh
annual clearance work would be
undertaken i would just like
that part to be noted i that all the
um local residents are very very pleased
with the work
that has been done um and i would like
to thank
rochford district council and a our
department and working together to
actually get this
actually done and i just want
confirmation
that this is now on the annual clearance
schedule i just need that assurance
please
thank you very much councillor warden
i'm sure that will be noted in the notes
but
i'm sure various officers
have noted those comments
okay councillor williams
you're on mute counselor williams
sorry thank you chairman i can confirm
that that is the case that they are
constantly checked and maintained thank
you that's that's good news thank you
very much indeed and it's nice to
have that positive note um okay if
there's no
further points to raise under that
section um
certainly dave i would like to thank you
and in no way were my earlier comments
attributed to
you in respect of essex county council
thank you very much indeed for
attending i'm sure you'll have more
comments to make in
other questions as they come up but a
sincere thank you to
to to you for your uh responsibility in
attending this meeting thank you very
much
and moving on then to
essex county council highways not much
really we can
cover on there as they don't uh bother
to turn up to the meeting so
uh um i don't know whether uh
our own officers are able to uh update
us on anything
uh to do with the items under
the highways coming are there any anyone
wishing to raise any comments
um i'm going to go to jeff stacy first
yes i've been in touch with
richard baronovsky this morning from
essex county highways
but the updates we've we've been through
uh really focus on the
uh the questions that were that were
posed
uh many of which pick up on the areas
which uh
are in the the past minutes anyway so
so if i may i'll i'll leave his comments
and
until we deal with the the questions
that have been received
from uh members of the public through
the council website later on in the
agenda
okay now thank you for that and
certainly there needs to be a tie up
as i said to you previously there needs
to be a tie up between the questions
that are being raised currently
and asked if you like history uh
from last year's meeting last january's
meeting so
uh i'd certainly appreciate that council
stanley
thank you chairman um one point i would
like to bring up for essays county
council
and and i'm sure the the people the
councillors
will understand this in london road um
we uh russia district council through uh
caroline of the waste uh department
had the ditch cleared outside of the
shops opposite near enough opposite um
can you can you just tell us to what
item that relates on what page are you
on please
i i'm just asking for
um essays county council to
update give us an update well
councilman stanley i'm specifically
going through the section that relates
to the
notes i mean you're most welcome to
raise it but i would like to keep some
order
in the sense of relating to that section
my apologies my opinion
no problem no problem at all councillor
shaw lauren sure that is
thank you chairman on page five um
pages from soakaway on the 27th the
first it said the funding and it says
here was slipped back to 2021.
um i know uh we've had very difficult
circumstances with the pandemic
but the pub at pagletron is continually
flooding and i'd like our essex county
councillors to actually go back and ask
um
essex county highways what has been done
have they
found the funding for this because they
did say it was going to be a vast amount
um and at the last pegglesham um
parish council meeting i was asked if i
could bring this up
thank you thank you councillor lauren
shaw and i would certainly like to
endorse that point
that um uh as award councillor
uh for that area along with councillor
iodo and yourself councillor shaw
um we have been vigorous and frankly to
see it's still not resolved it's not
good enough
and so yes i would like that
escalated please but uh in the absence
of
the appropriate body here bit difficult
to know how we're going to escalate it
councillor weston
thank you chairman yeah just uh just a
quick one
um kevin bentley sent me an email
yesterday to
have a meeting with outside bodies to do
with and i know that michael moore and
council michael
will bring it up to do with lower road
uh we're having a big meeting i'm just
waiting for the information just to let
you know on that score
obviously this isn't my area but i'm
hoping to get uh counselor
uh the new counsellor in that area to
get involved but just so you know that
this isn't western can you just refer me
to the item on the page please
okay thank you
thank you
so you're mute counselor western sorry
i'm just yeah sorry chairman i just
thought
you know let you know that was the essex
what we were doing i think council
stepped over talk more on the publishing
one
thank you chairman right i'm just keen
that we stick to the notes
and the specific items as i said to
council stanley just at this stage so
i'm keen to reference that section
council award
yeah thank you very much chairman yeah
it's two items
um we've got uh on page five
eastwood rise um that is an ongoing
problem
it's a legal wrangle that's going on uh
which has yet to be sorted but the
problem
remains the problem remains is that
the water misses the drains and this has
been
going on for several years and essex
refuses to accept responsibility
for that area at all that's a legal
issue that's ongoing
uh the other item is uh on page six last
item
eastwood road uh drains blocked
uh we haven't had this still happens
they are blocked
um and as far as i'm concerned i would
be
remiss if i didn't raise and continue to
raise
these items uh because they need both of
them need attending
uh council award thank you very much
indeed no doubt you will involve the
county councillor for the area uh in the
absence of highways being attending
here this morning um on those two issues
council has stepped up
thank you with regards to the issue at
peggle shrimp at the pub there
um i have uh been working with the
uh clerk for um pakistan past council
he did ask me to correspond with cancer
bentley on this particular point which i
have been doing so
it's quite a complicated issue as i
understand it
uh the where the soak away for the
uh pub is uh is they believe on private
land although it's water coming off
of the highway the main issue is
that um the soak away does not have an
outlet um and because of the surrounding
properties or private property
uh there isn't currently an outlet for
that
water to run to so they are trying to
resolve
that particular part of the issue um
that is i understand it was the last
communication i had about
two three weeks ago on that matter
lovely thank you very much indeed for
that uh
update jeff stacy you want to come in
yes just on the the peggle from side of
things um
it was one of the questions raised and
i've had a update from
uh essex highways sorry i'm just looking
this this up um they're saying it was
passed across to be further investigated
for
a remedial surface water alleviation
scheme
which at this time is with their design
team
thank you very much thank you very much
right okay members uh moving on to the
next
without going back and checking the
notes but i also believe that it is on
the list for the lhp to deal with as
well
yes i believe that's correct as well um
thank you
right moving on to the next section um
and
we feature here not because we have
a particularly key part to play because
as i say
flooding is not a statutory
responsibility for watchful district
council it is the partner agencies that
have that responsibility
but nevertheless there are some items
for there and i'm not quite sure
jeff is it you that's going to talk us
through the watchful district council
items there
yes i can do yeah
all right maybe a minute just gonna get
those up on my screen
sorry i'll be within a second
and yes as the the comment there through
um the route through to arnwell lane
that's been
provided there the issue on timberwolf
cottages
uh i made a lot of inquiries on that i
cannot find anybody who
who knows what the issue is there um
so this i've certainly not come across
anything in in terms of any essex county
council investigations
nor anybody who seems to know what what
the issues were there
so i must have been i have drawn a blank
there unless
anybody else can advise me on on that
one
okay is anyone able to help on that in
terms of the history of the item
finding that it will drop off of the
notes if we're not able to
uh shed some lights on it
i'm not seeing any um
what i would would suggest you do jeff
bees is perhaps just
liaise with the water councillors for
that area
yes yes i have right okay
well then it disappears off of the uh
item
right okay moving on um
the great wakering open ditch
um i didn't get any update on on that
one either so again i'm not really aware
what the
uh the the the sort of issue there is
i've not been able to sort of follow up
on
on that one um
okay it sounds like similar to the last
thing yeah
um and then the the sanctuary housing
area
i have been in touch with sanctuary
housing
uh uh we have discussed with them the
uh maintenance of that sort of area
um to to you know make sure that that is
maintained
um and i see the note there that
council and mrs lomley was uh
also going to to raise that matter with
them
okay um
so do we do we believe it's done
chairman can i come in please
counselor right yes certainly capstone
um i'm also on the committee and i can
confirm that uh council alumni did our
sanctuary
and they did clear it they well they
advised they had cleared it now
i haven't had any clarification from any
of the war members
and if that's not the case if they could
let me know i will then go back
and speak to on the next meeting speak
to um
sanctuary again i know she did actually
put it up did ask them
that's kind of you counselor mrs lauren
shaw
councillor macpherson
um sorry i popped my hand up for the um
item at chapel lane great waking
um i'm new to the flood forum
i know uh councillor steptoe may be able
to say why this item was on here
but i'm reluctant to have it taken off
um
if it's okay i will go visit the
residents down there and see
if there's any outstanding issue first
that's kind councilman person but what
i'm keen is that these
items are addressed and then they
disappear having been actioned
um but clearly i don't want them to
disappear before their action if that
makes sense so uh
i appreciate that
yes joey in response to councilman
there uh i don't recall this off the top
of my head but
i will try and go through some notes
that i have from previous meetings to
see if i can
uh identify what that is and if i can
i'll come back to you later in the
meeting
that's kind of you thank you very much
indeed um jeff did you want to finish
off on any other items
uh yes the uh the final one there
um kingsman farm road um
yes that was referred to to to planning
enforcement
um but uh i must have had an opportunity
to update with them as yet as to
what happened with that
okay
[Music]
sorry so
we're going through notes from 27th of
january 2020
um 14 months on um what's the delay
there then
uh it may well have been been actioned
as i said
unfortunately i just haven't had a
chance to uh to check up on that one
okay could you make that a priority
please because otherwise these things
just
drift don't they um one of the i think
downsides of this meeting is that
um it's a little infrequent um to pursue
these actions so
uh you know well i'm leader of this
council and
while i'm running this meeting i just
want to make sure that
actions are actioned um if that makes
sense councillor gooding
i i'd just like to ask through you chair
the uh if jeff stacey
followed up on the um the jetting
of the the railway light of the railway
um bridge sorry in rectory road i did
email you jeff and you said you'd be
talking on that sorry
councillor gooding where does that
relate to in this item
the item that jeff was talking i thought
he'd finished on all the items that he
was speaking on
and i didn't want him to leave this
as as for councillor stanley i will
bring members in
later on with any new items that they
wish to
raise but i don't want a so-called muddy
the waters
i want to keep it very crisp on the
notes from last year that's where we are
just at the moment but thank you
councilman
um right are you completed with your
update report uh jeff
hey thank you lovely thank you uh moving
on to
the environment agency your big moment
roger webster
um come on down here you are on morning
morning chair
um yeah there's a couple of items on
page eight
so the first one is the brook behind the
new development in london road rayleigh
i know it's a year on i'm presuming
we've carried on
maintaining that and clearing that as
part of our program
um i've had no response back from any of
the councils so
i'm presuming that's okay no i'm not
i'm not seeing anyone suggesting to the
contrary so you got off on that one
right the second item was the
lower wyverns wood flood alleviation
scheme on eastwood brook
uh as you can see we worked as part of
an integrated urban drainage scheme with
rochford essex county council dave's
team
to try and resolve the issue so this
came about
from the flooding a few years ago at
raley weir
where the um the pumps failed and then
they picked up and they
flushed a load of water through that
system
which affected some of the properties
that backed on to eastwood brook
so what we did was we did an initial
assessment in 2019
and we were working with one of the
councillors i think it was councillor
steptota though i'm not sure um
i've got council alumni here but anyway
we were looking to see
whether they could use the lower wyburns
wood as a temporary flood
storage area do if a similar situation
occurred again
but unfortunately the cost benefit ratio
for that was too low
based on the numbers of properties
affected the evidence we could get from
the locals
[Music]
so therefore we couldn't progress that
that option as part of the scheme
the other issue was um essex county
council highways own the screen which is
just downstream on lower why burns road
uh the local residents there said that
needed clearing regularly
beyond the regular maintenance that
essex county council highways
were doing i think from memory that
the highways team were up in the
maintenance program down there
to keep the screen cleared um
the other issue there was when we were
working with
um ready town council and rochester
district council
there was a call to send out letters to
local residents because there was issues
of
um garden waste going into the channel
which was blocking up the screen
prematurely which meant the water was
backing up and putting properties at
risk
and also about a year ago we did
call for any residents if they could
give us evidence
of flooding within the properties there
could have been an option of putting
property level resilience
to some of the properties i don't know
where that went
post that about a year ago but that
offer was there at the time
so if they had evidence surveys could
have been done and uh
property level resilience could have
been put in place
um the final thing i was going to add is
yeah i echo what
um dave chapman and uh
council stanley has said i haven't heard
of a date from marcus at the moment but
yes we we are happy to have a meeting to
discuss to see what can be done upstream
of roar of the moor of shot okay all
right
um look you know we'll be having another
what i call a proper meeting
um in the autumn and i really do want
to um feel that some of these things
have been proactively addressed because
it's quite apparent that some of them
drift on um
and we need a clear action plan um you
know
by definition some of them drift off
because they need to drift on because
it's
contingent on other uh things happening
like planning applications being
approved but
we need to be putting tight on this
counselor
thank you chairman um with regard to
lara wyburns
going back this was part of south end
uh borough council becoming involved in
this because they were the ones that
were recipient of the flooding
not only the residents in raleigh but
down in eastwood and the whole way down
uh that channel towards rochefort
yes because it wasn't just rainy that
that little group of residents there it
was all the way down the eastwood road
yes i was gonna yeah sorry councillors
sparring yes you're right um the scheme
has carried on
as i believe it i've i've moved away
from that but south end
are carrying that forward so they are
looking
to uh fund improvements downstream
you're quite correct and there was
greater numbers of properties
downstream that were affected by
flooding um
so yes you're quite correct that's
carrying on
right okay thank you and and clearly
water doesn't stop moving just because
it crosses a boundary of a um
you know district and a uh a borough uh
you know there needs to be
a joint working on these things i
sometimes think that
people work attempting to work in silos
and uh
well at south end or that's essex or
that's something else
and you know walter doesn't sort of say
oh well because i've hit the south end
boundary i'll stop flooding
um if i could just
that they relocated the flood monitor
from south end airport to lower y burns
because this is where the problems were
all starting so there is a flood monitor
down in there
in the lower by burns area now um
councillor spain are you talking about
the uh the gauging station there yeah
yeah yeah so that was another thing i
was going to say we put a gauging
station in there to monitor the flows
and also it's worth saying that um
essex county council highways um
did improve the the rayleigh weir pumps
so hopefully that situation won't occur
again
okay fingers crossed i should say yeah
that's always a technical assessment
yeah okay thank you thank you thanks for
sparing
uh dave chapman you wanted to come in
yeah it was just to follow on really
from what roger has said is that um
south end are taking a lead on this we
have
uh quite a large amount of modelling
information that's been recently updated
as well and they've requested that we
share that with them so we're in the
process of
sharing all of the most current
up-to-date modeling information that we
have for that particular location
uh and it's low south end to lead but
east essex county council have offered
assistance where needed in terms of
either delivery or resources and
whatever
so we're waiting for south end to then
just take that forward as and when they
they see fit
and um that's lovely sorry uh councillor
stepped up
thank you chairman uh two things uh one
with regards to the residents in
eastwood not necessarily on our side of
the border
although some of them are in my ward uh
i am receiving emails and there's still
a great concern about the
the flow of the the stream through there
uh
i don't know whether you want to take it
now chairman uh but i have found the
notes
with regards to chapel lane uh if you
want me to
go through that at this moment or you
want to leave that till later now
i'm referring to the um notes that were
presented at the last
uh meeting uh and it's the notes of the
meeting held on the 8th of november 2018
and it says and i read what it says
chapel lane open ditch was
was cleared in 2015 but now part of the
banking collapsing into the ditch
angular water re-routed part of the
piped ditch
into an open ditch in 2016.
five residents are badly affected uh
and then as the note say determine who
the land owner is
records to be checked by rdc
um i believe that part of chapel lane
and i'm sure thousand visible correct if
i'm wrong here
is actually an adopted road unmade road
i think it refers to that section
of trouble but i'm just reading what i
have in the notes here
okay that's that's helpful thank you
council
right um moving on then to anglia water
the last part of last year's notes
and mark lloyd if i could bring you in
please
it looks can i see mark lloyd
oh yes i can see him uh but i can't hear
him
when i say i can see him he's not got
his camera on but uh
no no
so that good old camera off trick and uh
he's not not
behind the screen at the moment mark are
you there
no okay uh council award
yeah thank you very much chairman yeah
um i i did want to speak on this
particular item because
i'm the councillor who has brought that
forward it's not in my
my area but uh as portfolio hold and
still am
i was very concerned about
the whole issue in regards to this
drawbacks there may have been in regards
to
the permissions granted for planning
this is a serious issue that needs to be
resolved
and you know i would ask that uh it is
kept on
it is looked at and it needs to be
resolved and i think
um you know there is this goes across
you know all all authorities including
iran
um because we granted planning
permission on this area
which definitely had a stream
uh running through the middle of it okay
can i see whether mark lloyd is
okay um well there's no kind of mark
lloyd right sorry to cut your council
award but uh
you know i think we just have to take it
as an action forward um
your point is well made seven for me
council williams thank you chairman um i
have just
uh messaged mark ryder with to no avail
thank you chairman on and of course we
can't have anything
because he's not here but on the very
last page
um new developments including uh and
claim
councillor george at the canudan parish
council
had said he'd been there was we knew
there was chinese
drainage issues and there was a blockage
and he knew where it was he'd had
meetings so perhaps uh counselor wanna
who could actually
advise us what has been done on it as we
can't have angry and walters
to tell us thank you
well um that's right council sure i mean
i take it that any other business was
of a more general nature and i was
hoping that uh jeff stacy could update
us on any
specifics on on uh any other business
can you help us on that jeff i do
apologize chair i jumped page
no that's all right no problem at all
jeff i see any other business is that
something you can help us on your mute
at the moment
uh yes what i'll do is i'll update on
the um
a number of uh flooding issues that
we've
that have been reported through to
rochford district council
as well as picking up on the uh
questions that have come through on to
to our website um
is is this are we talking here about the
whole bridge
area are we talking about the last four
items on page nine
right
my screen is not keen on having too many
things up at the same time right okay
would you like me to share my screen
chairman
uh yes you can do barwins
right it's those last four items jeff
yes i'm on my notes of an update on the
lower road
[Music]
yes the others i've no update on
no no i can't uh i can't help with the
others i don't think
right okay well again it's the
inadequacy of essex
council highways not being here so most
unsatisfactory
um i can't belabor that point enough
councillor stepdo you wish to come in
thank you chairman with regards to the
last item there millview meadows
i know some resurfacing work has since
been carried out
since these notes were made i personally
have not received any further complaints
on this
issue i don't know if council williams
has as the other ward councillor
but as far as i'm concerned i believe
the matter has been resolved
lovely thank you very much indeed for
that uh councillor williams
yeah thank you chairman you know
millview meadows i think that was
surfaced um
although much of it is block paving it i
think that seems to
resolve that issue as far as a lower
road judge with ashland road
is it's still an issue there but
unfortunately being in the bottom of a
hill
in heavy rain i don't think there's an
awful lot of place in the water to go
but it does clear away quite quickly now
thank you
thank you for that um councillor stanley
thank you chairman uh with the relevance
to uh
goose cottages um the water leak is
still leaking
um andy and walter have looked at it and
said it's not theirs
and so i don't know who to
or who can resolve that uh it's still
coming out of the path
um maybe that's something for
to be held on to yep okay thanks
councillor stanley and i'm sure a note
has been made of that uh
councillor iron you're a visiting member
to this uh committee but uh you're most
welcome to uh
make a point yes with regards to knuden
just to let you know chairman
um i did have a meeting uh
with essex highways and they did do an
on-site visit and they've acknowledged
that there is a blockage
in the the drains there and have taken
the report away and will be scheduling
uh
the unblocking of the drains at some
point in the future but they didn't give
me
uh an estimated time to when that would
be done
thank you as i do i mean this seems to
be a general theme that people have
meetings they look and they inspect but
they don't actually give us a time when
things are going to be done
which frankly isn't good enough um i've
been used in the business world to
identifying a problem and
then you actually target a date to
resolve these things but uh
it seems a more relaxed approach and
frankly it's just not good enough
councilman um chairman it's only a quick
point um i have a resident who
has been in contact with one of mark
lloyd's colleagues
so um hopefully if you keep trying our
anglian
water representative he may respond
thank you okay then
thank you very much indeed for that
that's helpful councillor weston
yes thank you chairman that was the one
with the ashington road um
i have emailed essex county they have
sent me that
um a reply which i sent down to debbie
constable
i will send that on to whoever wants it
if they like but they are
doing something on in that area thank
you chairman
okay thank you very much indeed um right
okay that takes us on
to um i'm not sure whether any of our
partners here want to make any further
verbal updates we've been through the
notes in some detail
but i am keen to get onto questions from
the
public unless jeff you've got any issues
you wish to raise under
item five
and yes i'll um
run through very quickly the um
areas that have been identified not
through the questions but
through other contact with rochford
district council
and it's really just to to sort of flag
up that we are aware of these issues
um and and sort of well look we'll look
into them
um but we had a number of uh
sort of notifications of issues
following the heavy rain on the 14th of
january this year
um and we'll be looking into stuff
around clements hall
we've been working with hockley parish
council on the maryland's nature reserve
there was an individual case on woodside
chase in hawkwell um
there was the issues on the the railway
bridges particular railway uh
rectory road um but
in in the past in the flood forum we
have uh agreed and increased
uh sort of jetting and cleaning with
with highways so that that
should clear a lot quicker now
um there was a report of flooding in old
london road roarworth
um and the the usual along watery lane
uh on that day we've also had reports
around uh plumbrow avenue
um um and in particular contact from mr
james hall which
we'll be sort of picking up on
the ashington road and greenswood lane
junction which
we've mentioned already canoed and apton
hall road
a number of issues around holdbridge
some related to the dome some related to
grasmere avenue
and mayland's lane which um
is the the one that council award was
was mentioning
and uh we'll be having some further
discussions
with uh andrew andrew waite
from barrett david wilson homes
to to sort of look at that um
engelfield close and rectory road
hawkwell that was to do with
uh clearing of the waterways there which
has been done
still issues coming up around great
wakering high street
um the burnham drive roarworth
was was mentioned but we've established
contact with greenbelt who managed the
site and
details have been passed contact details
have been passed to residents
mocking hall little wakering
a specific case in braised lane
ashington
some new bungalows built round there
plow and sail paglesson which we've
we've mentioned in the update there
belchamps grout camp hawkwell
elizabeth gardens on hall road rochford
and swain park um
i say all of those are have
been raised uh as queries with rockford
district council
um and we will look into those
to get some replies back to the the
people who've made the inquiries
okay all right thank you for that um
and they will be incorporated in these
notes with actions against them so that
we can really pick them up in our autumn
meeting
that's that's the intention that as you
say the notes from this meeting
will to a great extent form a list of
those areas where we've been notified of
issues
and as you say we'll report back in the
autumn of
uh progress on all those areas right
okay
all right thank you very much indeed um
really the most important section of
this meeting
is the um engagement with
members of the public who raise
questions what i intend to do is go
through those
individual questions so that we can
assign um what we can
do i said council award you've got your
hand up
thank you that was on the last report
from uh from jeff
um just on the mountains lane thing and
i know that uh councillor hoy
he's got his hand up now um i think he
wants to come in if we may
on this one fundamentally we went there
to visit
the issue of the flooding um
that's coming off the rear of the
properties at manians
it would appear that this is an angling
water problem
on their own surface water pipes
uh that's why it's disappointing that
mark lloyd has kind of kind of
disappeared
but um we were hoping and i think it's
best
if you have a conversation with andrew
white
who is the senior engineer at bdw
um who may be able to help on a couple
of issues not only this one
but also the watery lane he has a lot of
expertise
in this area and was was happy to talk
about
other solutions thank you okay
thank you council award uh i'm keen to
get on to these questions because i
think this will sweep up a number of
these issues but uh
um councillor steptoe yeah just picking
up on the point on great white queen
high street
uh i am aware of this particular issue
and have been pursuing it along
with uh highways there is a
possible capacity issue with the the
gullies that are on that particular side
of the road where it's not a problem on
the other side
uh but as yet i haven't had a report
back as to what action will be taken
okay uh council ohio i think i saw your
hand up but it's uh up and down up and
down but i think councillor walters made
the point um if there's anything
else on excel hope y'all can come in at
the very end that's all
yeah no that's exactly what i'm planning
to do uh for
members information is look at all these
questions run through them
because there's actually been 14
questions i think it is that have come
in
from 13 questions that have come in from
members of the public
um and i want those integrated into the
various parts of our um
plan moving forward and then i certainly
want any
to take any points from council so i'm
i'm planning the next
half an hour will be devoted uh if we
get through it faster but
get through these questions um so that
they can be integrated i'm not
necessarily expecting there to be
uh immediate answers to them but uh um
if i go through the um questions jeff is
that all right with you
uh yes and i have got quite a few
comments
uh back from um
uh essex county highways which which uh
do relate to a lot of these questions
well it's nice for them to send their
comments back showing they can't attend
in person isn't it
um because it's just it's just no use
i mean i don't know how strongly i need
to make that point but
having their comments really doesn't
give engagement and it's most
unsatisfactory but
um you will have gathered i'm not
impressed and question one the
environment agency needs to check out
the various blockages
in hawkwelt brook between clements hall
and windsor gardens
it is a designated river and these
blockages need to be removed to reduce
the flooding risk
i don't know whether anyone wishes to
make any comment i mean these will all
be integrated yes um
i can do a chair um i've had an update
this morning um
our guys went through there yesterday
and have cleared it looks like from the
pictures i've got
branches and bricks were in the channel
which they've cleared
um they haven't done the banks because
that's not part of the program
at the moment and we remind local
landowners
to clear their banks you know
proportionally as well but we have
cleared the channel down there
thank you for that roger um can i just
come in on a general point i mean there
are a number of ditches and waterways
that do run across private ground
and i do wonder what we do to make those
people
aware of their responsibilities because
the trouble is they fill this stuff
up with their own garden waste because
they think it's a sort of
an area that they can you know just put
garden and to be fair in the middle of
summer
uh who could possibly ever think these
places are gonna get a flood but
with our uh the type of climate we have
um you know unfortunately
they are required they're a part of our
infrastructure and i sometimes think
that there is a lax approach
towards ensuring that homeowners and
householders meet their responsibilities
to
firstly not tip their rubbish into it
because that's not what they're intended
for
and secondly to remind them of their
responsibilities to keep them maintained
generally maintained what goes on um
to make that happen roger
you're mute
you continue to be on mute sorry yes um
it's a continual problem that we uh
encounter we've got some guidance on the
gov dot uk website and i can share that
with you
with regard to riparian responsibilities
when we're able to we do do letter drops
to remind
people exactly you know the issues
you're talking about
that they have a responsibility even
though it may be a main river
we don't actually own main rivers we
work under our permissive powers
under the uh water resources act to
clear us
when we need to we haven't got a finite
amount of money we can't
keep clearing these channels out we do
target the money the best we can
um as i say i can share the link
uh with regard to riparian
responsibilities and ownership if that's
helpful
but it is a perpetual problem we rely on
the councils
the the councillors to remind people
when they're out that they have a
responsibility
of keeping the channel clear you know
where they're
actually land ownership of that part of
the channel
lovely okay thank you very much indeed i
mean i i
i understand the issue but uh we do need
to constantly remind people
of their their duties but to see people
just piling in their
garden rubbish especially when we're so
good at providing green beans
um you know i never understand why
people need to actually put their normal
garden waste
in these ditches um because they do
actually serve a purpose
absolutely um out of sight out of mind
is the problem
i think you're absolutely right there
councilman stanley yes i
quite concur with you chairman um but
but at the same time
it is um i don't know whether it's
lawful or not lawful
for them to cut their hedgerows down and
leave the debris behind in the ditches
which is often the case
and i just wondered if it's possible
that um
a bit more uh uh work could be
involved well like for lethality in
those areas where the
where the landowners have got ditches
and and know and should know their
rights and what
what there should be yes yes thank you
councillor stanley and
certainly i think we ought to take this
offline because i think
you know when you look at munched-up
grass verges which seems particularly
topical at the moment
you look at hedges that overgrow
pavements you look at cars that are
parked on pavements which i really
realized a different thing you know
these things uh
all contribute to make pedestrian life
quite quite difficult sometimes walking
down
their roads but it's about reminding
people of their responsibilities but uh
i won't roll too far into that area
counselor step though
thank you chairman um one of the
problems with ditches of course
is those that run across the more rural
areas of farmland
can i suggest that perhaps at a future
meeting uh that we have a representative
from the
national farmers union uh that might be
useful to have them along
on board to actually uh remind them
the larger landowners of some of their
responsibility keeping their ditches
clear as well because most ditches run
into the funding
yep i think that's a a point well made
moving on to the second question
with the issue of surface flooding being
of importance is the council going to
look into
uh and adopt north street after heavy
rainfall
the footpath becomes extremely difficult
to navigate
and the houses that all pay their
council tax struggle to access
their own homes it is somewhat of a
danger on this
footpath at these times anyone care to
comment on that
jeff
yes a comment back from highways on this
the assumption is this relates to north
street great wakering which is
designated as a as a private road
um it's what he's suggesting it seems to
be that
it's not something that adoption happens
automatically that
um you know they'd need to make a
request to essex county council
who would provide relevant information
regarding requirements for
adoption standards and processes
okay councilman
thank you chairman i think that the
issue here as well is the fact that a
footpath
runs through this road it is unadopted
as um jeff
quite rightly pointed out but there is a
footpath um
unless um exits county council have
visited
highways have visited the road um and as
they can't come to a virtual meeting i
fear that they haven't
it would be quite good if they actually
visited it because trust me if somebody
does fall down and they hurt themselves
on that road
i wonder if they're culpable boys it's a
footpath thank you
thank you councillor
yes thank you chairman i have had quite
a lot of correspondence on this
particular issue
uh if the war counsellors and the
questioner would like to contact me
offline
uh i will cover what uh responses i've
had from
essex county on this matter lovely thank
you um
right i'll move on to the third question
i've got to move on a bit of a pace uh
but long
couple of questions now we live on the
hull bridge road offset lavar's farm
and was severely affected by the floods
in 2013 this was due to the ditch not
being able to cope with the amount of
water
which then subsequently entered the
sewer system by the flooded road
this has also happened on two further
occasions
after a lot of telephone calls emails in
contact with the local authority
it was finally discovered that the ditch
that runs alongside the road is owned
and maintained by essex county council
we have two questions in relation to
this why has the ditch never been
maintained
the only maintenance that is carried out
is to cut back overhanging trees and
vegetation
which are then have to fall back into
the ditch blocking it further
i was told by a local resident of over
50 years that when the ditch was first
there
it was nearly five foot deep so where is
it's nowhere near there that's now
and then secondly is in relation to the
fencing and footbath which runs along
the side of the ditch
the fencing has been non-existent for at
least 10 years
with this being the only footpath for
that road is also a very poor repair
with potholes and cracks i recently
witnessed the gentleman on a mobility
scooter
almost lose control and fall into the
road with the increase in usage
especially with the extra housing in the
area
it will only be a matter of time before
someone falls into the ditch
or has an injury caused by the poor
footpath
if you could tell tell us the proposed
program to maintain the ditch
fencing and footpath it would be greatly
appreciated
right okay um some of these i'm going to
just suggest
that we deal with them otherwise you
know we can't debate each question that
he goes through
but councillor stanley you want to come
in
thank you chairman uh this is one of the
items that
i wanted to bring to your notice um and
also
the ditch uh running uh as far
as the uh tesco's express that is the
same ditch that is supposed to be
running alongside london road it um
we had or should i say uh an
rdc officer caroline had the uh
ditch uh cleared out at the at the
front of the shops in london road
and then the rest of it belongs to essex
county council
which she has made inquiries to
essex county council and yet no
forthcoming information has come from
them
and this is exactly this is this is
exactly what happens it floods and and
what have you so
yes this should be left on the agenda
for
maybe uh jeff stacy to inquire yep okay
don't agree with that uh and i'm getting
a nod from him but do you want to say
anything jeffrey
yes another one where i've had a reply
from essex highways
our understanding is that the ditch
historically has been maintained by
essex county council highways
i'm not aware of any blocked areas and
the ditches viewed and inspected as part
of routine
or ad hoc inspections of holbridge road
the ditch was extensively
attended and further cleared in 2014.
i will however arrange for a visit here
to look at the current condition
so an action there from them um in
relation to the post and rail fence
i am aware that sections are missing and
we are unaware of when or why this fence
was installed
there are sections missing and these
have been risk assessed by the
inspection team
and at this time are not deemed to be of
high priority for repair
and then on the footpath along holbridge
road
will also have been risk assessed and
any defects of high priority will have
been attended
i am not aware of any plans to resurface
or significantly patch this footway at
this time
thank you thank you very much um
right i've really got to move this along
otherwise we're not going to get through
the questions but
uh uh if i can ask for points to be
brief um
council ahoy thank you chairman um this
comes under
my world holbrook road um
the ditch has not been cleared to any
significant extent
extent not even in 2014 it does need
maintenance it
does need to doing um the
the fence along the side used to be
cleared by the essex highway rain used
to be sorry the fence used to be sorted
out by the essex highway rangers
as they come under rdc now i assume it's
become our responsibility as the
district council to replace the fence
um as to the footpath for the path i
mean
these two subjects are off the flood
forum anyway they're really other
other issues the footpath is in a
dreadful state from
where the new cycleway finishes um
and it does need completely resurfacing
but obviously that's a separate issue
which should be taken up with essex
okay thank you very much councillor yeah
chairman i'm just a little confused
councillor stanley was referring to
a ditch along london road opposite the
tesco express
i think that's a completely separate
issue isn't it
i think it is actually i must admit when
i look back at the question i've read i
don't see the linkage to london road my
my apologies
i got mixed up sorry okay all right um
right moving on to question council
sparing
thank you chairman can i just say you
with regard to council of war
councillor um hoy's comments
when rdc took over the highway rangers
they took over the highway rangers they
didn't take over all their
responsibilities
that worked with essex county council at
the time
and nothing has come attached to the
highway rangers
thank you chairman thank you very much
indeed um
i want to move on to question four i'm a
south end unsea borough council and on
behalf of my eastwood residents
we are concerned about waterways that we
share with rockford district council and
their management
will watch for district council be
supportive of ensuring a good
and proactive dialogue with its
neighbours thank you i think the answer
to that is yes and we touched on that
subject
earlier um you know water doesn't stop
running just because it crosses a
uh a district or a borough um area
um we live in lower road opposite the
valley farm
and it is well documented regarding the
problems with the culvert on the south
side of lower road
the road was severely flooded for a
total of 31 days from the 15th of
november 20
to the 26th of january 21 works were
undertaken on the 23rd
sorry i believe on the 27th of january
31 to clear the blocked pipes leading
from the culvert
with matters improving since then albeit
with much less rainfall
i recently heard from ecc that they
anticipate investigating the possibility
of undertaking
further additional drainage works on the
site i feel that the culvert
is in a very poor condition and
yesterday i had to remove some items
which were likely to have caused further
blockages i therefore would like to ask
if the culvert could be repaired
and some form of cover be installed to
ensure debris
does not enter the culvert it could be
considered dangerous as someone
somebody could fall into it especially
at night so that really
is an observation rather than a question
uh
by council of western mr
chairman anything like this i am keeping
on on board with essex county i am
looking at this one as well
uh jeff stacy i have something to say
but also i understand part of it belongs
to the
uh a landowner as well which obviously
we're having to to sort out thanks
yes and thank you for that point that's
often the case that actually people
think that
uh is within the council's
responsibility
whichever council uh turns out sometimes
to be their own responsibility but
uh um there we are uh councillor michael
hoy
yeah thank you sorry to keep watching um
yeah councillor
kevin bentley at six was very helpful in
clearing the culvert
and the reports back from the people who
cleared it
as an urgent matter did say that the the
culvert did need
working on it it goes under the road but
lower road at that point
um so obviously it's quite a major bit
of work if they need to
to do any roadblocks there need this
closure of a pr route
um the ditches along the side of the
road on the south are still
flooded so there's clearly a blockage
somewhere there and i'd be grateful if
you could keep this on the
agenda from that point of view for
actions to be taken
certainly will do jeff did you want to
come in there
uh yes just with the comment from uh
essex highways
we are aware of the issues here and it
is currently being further investigated
by the essex highways drainage team
which i think was indicated in the in
the comment
um anyway so uh
that really just confirms that lovely
thank you for that
um right question six flooding during
and after moderate to heavy rain outside
houses two five one
and either side of high street great
wakering have been
reported several times with latest
update date for reference two four four
zero
seven eight eight being worked complete
however recent rain has highlighted this
issue has not been resolved
the flooding continues with the drain
outside two five one
big two five three quickly becoming
overwhelmed
as indicated previously this poses a
significant risk to children
and other adults leaving these houses we
are not aware of flooding at either
drain
either side of the affected drain which
again has been mentioned several times
during previous reports
of surface flooding with essex highways
we're also not aware of any issues with
the drains on the opposite side of the
road
i'm intrigued as to how these completed
works have been resolved
when the issue still persists with the
same level of planning
whether or not you have an answer on
that jeff
yes i have a comment uh on that one
um yes footwear works have been
undertaken at this location
as pre-patching prior to the surface
being overlaid
uh which may have been thought to have
dealt
with the inquiry well it's not worth it
very well but i think what he's saying
there is uh people may have thought that
the work's been finished but
it's in fact there's only preliminary
work um that they're doing
um he goes on to say i'm not aware of
any further issues
with the drainage system itself but can
direct jetting crew to this site to
clear gullies and jet the system
there is an angling water system in this
area to which i assume
our system connects um
that's the comment from uh highways
thank you
okay thank you council step down thank
you chairman i did refer to this
uh earlier on uh council mcpherson
mentioned
mentioned this uh i will pick this up
again with uh richard because
uh um his statement there he was i
wasn't aware of anything further
uh i'm certain he's incorrect um
there are concerns i have raised about
what's known as the topography
of the highway there as to how the water
runs
and where it flows to and there is some
issues about the capacity of the
particular gullies that we are in
question
if the questionnaire and also the award
council would like to contact me offline
on this
i will go through what uh process i've
been through
thank you very much indeed council step
down um right
moving on item seven question seven
iron roll lane was if not actually
flooded certainly very badly affected by
water a few weeks ago
the big runoff pipe from the new estate
suds
discharges directly into the lane side
ditch
which is so shallow and overgrown it
can't cope further up
it's the same but without the extra
input one simple answer would be a
modest size
culvert taking it over to the brook
which had plenty of headroom at the time
so i think that's just a
uh a point to take away councillor
steptoe
yes thank you chairman i have had a
number of uh issues
in and around the development of the
hall road state the elizabeth gardens
with regards to water runoff and various
ditches
particularly from those people that live
in oak road
which is alongside the i think a lot of
this
is being looked at by rocha district
council planning department because
as it's and the site is still under
development
uh there is some issues around the water
runoff from that
so that is something that is ongoing
thank you very much jeff
it's just a a highway
comment that this this is very much um
sorry this moves around every time i i
put my speaker on um
they're not aware of any actual highway
flooding in this area
so it's seeing that very much as ditch
maintenance which is the responsibility
of the
adjacent riparian owner so they're not
seeing that as a essex highways issue
right but i think it's again a
clarification of who owns the ditch
because obviously the owner might think
it's county and
county think it's the owner um so it's
making the owner
owners aware of their uh riparian
responsibility i would suggest
um dave chapman you want to come in
yeah i don't know the new development um
in person but just to reiterate that if
there are issues around
uh the runoff rates from any particular
drainage if
they if their ten dwellings are above or
a hectare and over they will have come
to our team for consultation
so i don't know what what size
development this one is but that may
have come to us if there is issues with
subs run off and calculations then by
all means contact us
and we will pass comment on anything
that potentially may be an issue
the same goes for riparian ownership
issues with the maintenance of a ditch
not just in this location but generally
if there are any inquiries that relate
to that issue then please
just send them over to us and we'll work
our way through them okay well
i mean i think the the key thing was imo
lane was not actually flooded
so it sounds as if that you know i mean
it's a maintenance issue rather than
necessarily a
flooding issue but uh um there we are
council stepped up
yeah germany [ __ ] come back on that
uh the ditch that i have
got in question uh we believe to be in
the
ownership of the developer at this stage
um but that needs to be confirmed and
waiting for it to confirm
i have raised the issue of the sad
calculations with
officers rdc but as of yet i haven't had
a response back from rdc
as to how they're taking those
calculations and issues forward
as i say is still a development the site
of some 600 properties um which
hasn't been fully resolved as far as
that's concerned so i'm still waiting
for
correspondence from rtc on it okay thank
you for that
um right next one is one we touched on
earlier when will the ongoing problem of
surface water outside the play on sale
public house be addressed
it has been going on forever with
promises of a solution but so far no
results
look that came up earlier um i'm as
well i'm nothing like as frustrating as
the owner would be but
it's an appalling issue it sits within
uh councillor lawrence
uh councillor iodo and my area and i
know much work has been done by the
world councillors collectively on that
it's not good enough it's simple as that
you should not have
a pub that is you know constantly
watching out for the slightest bit of
rainfall
it needs to be sorted and sorted it will
be but how we sort it we'll deal with
perhaps in the next meeting as
a defending action uh councillor lauren
shaw
on that note chairman i've just gone
through back through my notes and terry
catwald
first brought this up to um committees
in 2008 we and they
with pictures so it has been going on a
long time
it certainly has uh and um you're
absolutely right but we did have an
update and it will appear on the um
the defending list thank you council for
sure um
uh question nine moon's close high cliff
present
first raised up meeting 8th of november
2018 situation deteriorated over the
last
seven months raised with county council
has stepped on the 15th of january 21
essex county council highways reply will
raise again
with anglian water did this happen and
what was the outcome
can the drain be regularly jetted if the
problem is to do with the connections of
the main drain
lower road junction with greensward lane
first rate meeting 27th of january 2020
essex county council highways to look at
area did this happen there's no
improvement
in fact the flooding is worse range with
county council of western third of
february 21 adjacent to 621
ashington road problem for over six
years appears water runs off of creating
runs off a field creating a river along
the footway
and carriageway recent cold weather made
the road treacherous what steps are
being taken to alleviate this problem
possibility of a drainage ditch raised
with council county council of western
in february um so there's a number of
points there
i don't know whether anyone wishes to
comment jeff
uh yeah again i've got some comments
from the um
uh essex highways
on the first section um
it's picked up that's been discussed at
previous flood forum meetings
and uh elsewhere um it was attended in
december
but in our opinion we would ask again
ask england water
to further investigate their system in
the meantime
we will attend with jetting crew if
required
and the second question their comment is
the jetting crew attempted this work
but it was abandoned due to difficulties
with traffic management
road width is too narrow we are
currently investigating this with a view
to re-attendance as appropriate
and their comment on the final question
was we're not aware of any current
issues here
but can visit the site and investigate
further
okay well that will be integrated into
the actions from this meeting council
western
yes jim and i'm just going to say i'll
take all those on board which i've
already done anyway
thank you lovely thank you councillor
steptoe
yeah thank you chairman with regards to
the moon
close part of the situation as you can
see there
i have reported this to highways uh they
were raising the issue with angela
walter
i don't believe that they've received a
response from angela water on this
matter
i certainly haven't as at this stage
okay thank you for that
uh question 10 can anything be done
regarding the
consistent rain water flooding at the
junction where pointers lane meets
wakering road
it's an accident black spot as it is
with poor left and right
visibility when pulling out into
pointers lane
with many motorists already on the lane
not slowing down for potential hazards
such as cars of tempting to pull out
cyclists without lights
and people walking in the road thank you
so uh rainwater flooding at pointers
lane where it makes great ring road
uh well let's go to jeff stacy in case
there's a comment there and
uh
yes there is uh uh um
there is a comment from highways
sorry here it is uh we have looked at
the defects recorded and will attend the
gullies and drainage system at this
location
so an action indicated from them
thank you okay council respect though
yes thanks chairman uh this particular
junction is coming up
on the nhp uh paperwork i'm just
quickly looking at that i can't quickly
see it
but it is coming up as a scheme for the
lhp
uh to improve that particular junction
because there has been a number of
accidents
um uh there um the
design uh situation of that junction
and including some of the drainage has
been completed
it's now coming back to the lhp for
funding i believe for um to actually
carry out the necessary works so that
will appear on the agenda
um next week i think it is for the lhp
lovely thank you councilman
thank you chairman um as we know the lhp
will take a millennium
to come to um actually fund anything in
the meantime going back to what jeff
stacy said um highways need to go out
and address a lot of the
foliage around there it's all very well
clear in the drains but unless they're
going to address that it's only going to
repeat the same process
so if they can do that in conjunction
please jeff if you could ask that of
them thank you
thank you very much councillor weston
yeah just on the
uh aside um chairman mark lloyd said he
apologize difficulty technical issues
but he has some um answers to some of
your queries that are being asked
on the chat if you wanted to have a look
at that thank you chairman
okay all right well i'm going to ask um
jeff to
keep an eye on the chat or sonya to keep
an eye on the chat and uh we'll come in
at the end on that
and question 11 is an offer of help
rather than a question
so i will move on to 12. um
who is responsible for keeping the
stream between little wakering road and
kimberley road clear of obstruction and
stopping it from flooding
who is responsible for clearing the
street drains along little wakering road
where it rains some of them are blocked
and flood the road
jeff you let me comment on that
uh no i haven't i think this this one
must have arrived late or something i
have i haven't picked this up in the uh
the questions i discuss with highways
okay uh councillor steptoe
yeah thank you uh uh chairman uh this is
the one that i had to declare an
interest in the
barling creek stream that they're
referring to
um the uh dave chapman may wish to come
in on this particular point with regards
to the maintan aspect
i know he has been corresponding with
uh the um riparian land owners of this
particular stream
as far as the gullies are concerned
along little wakering road itself
um the gullies there are responsibility
of essex county council
they have had the gully sucker along
there over the last week or 10 days or
so
we did actually identify a couple of
gullies that
essex county council for some reason
weren't aware of
which have been dealt with as well
so i think that covers i think dave i
don't know if you want to
uh comment further on the uh aspect of
the way
and land ownership of the stream
yeah if you'd like me to share i can
just add um floods team input if you
like
um so so as councillor steptoe has
mentioned
riparian landowner letters have been
sent out
not just to one but a number of
properties that are riparian owners of
the particular stream in question um
we've had some responses back i think
there's been
uh and councillor mcpherson will
probably join there's been a little bit
confusion about some of the
work that has been done and some of the
issues that we're trying to raise with
those landowners
so we'll be following those up but
basically there is a there's a number of
landowners
some more than others that have a
responsibility to
address um bank issues that where
they're failing
uh falling into the ditch creating a
problem
those those will be addressed through
continued correspondence and there is
actually a site visit
uh in the diary for the next in the next
couple of weeks so that we can get the
engineer out there
just to look in detail and and follow up
any of those
questions that have been raised or
follow up with landowners about required
work that needs doing
lovely thank you um councilman
thank you chairman um uh thank you dave
i'm glad you gave a clearer update
obviously i had a very upset very
elderly
um lady who received a letter and
telling her that she had done
unconsented works luckily she had
a letter which she quickly produced
where she had
once upon a time done works all agreed
nor consented to
so i would just say a little bit of
caution when these letters are going out
as you rightly said dave there is one
landowner
who um is probably well
i think almost definitely responsible
for a lot of remedial work
but it put the fear of god up into some
of the other residents
um so that's my only comment just please
think before in perhaps get in touch
with us and we have a chat
and also if you let me know that date
that'd be wonderful
thank you thank you
very very swiftly if you will yeah just
to uh
confirm uh also as well going further
down the line with regards to the water
running into this uh
stream as i said uh uh lorena there's a
number of tributaries that run into that
i think it's either three or four
um i haven't been talking to officers at
essex as to what we can do to try and
slow down the water
uh running into this stream uh at an
earlier stage
uh the upstream of the contro tributes
uh with things like for example leaky
games that type of uh
systems so we don't get such a high
quantity of water right running into
this stream
at high tide uh
you um the final question is what will
be done to help the pumping station in
kimberley road cope with heavy rainfall
it hasn't been able to manage for the
last 20 years
enough is enough action needs to be
taken urgently
especially with more homes being added
to this system
any comment on that one councilman
councillors well let's go to councilman
first
uh thank you chairman um uh i don't know
if our representative from england
walter can actually type something
in the messenger that could be relayed
by sonja
but i would hugely appreciate a response
to this email
um as the residents rightly pointed out
it has been going on for some
considerable years now
um it will as you've said yourself
chairman only get worse
um with things like climate change um
i really think the residents need an
answer so if you can pop one over that
would be wonderful thank you
good thank you captain stephano
yes thank you uh we've got the pumpkin
station i have been talking to
officers at anger water they are trying
to identify
all of the various aspects of the
larger areas to what feeds into the
public station
there is some issues about too much
storm water getting into the
foul sewage system which needs to be
addressed uh so the capacity of the
pumping station
is far better there's also issues being
raised
as to whether the out full pipe from the
pumping station
is sufficiently large enough um there
has been some discussions on that
i'm waiting for officer the anger water
officers to come back to me
to arrange a meeting so all of those
concerned can discuss
this matter uh both residents at war
councillors etc
um to come back and discuss this matter
further with angela water
at a meeting thank you very much very
helpful councillor williams
yeah thank you chairman at the last
heavy rainfall when this was flooded
um i visited this site with the council
mike stepton councillor
mcpherson we went down there and had a
look a lot of the problems with the
drains then were the surface water
flooding due to
tidal lock the water was going into the
sewage system
but that weekend they were actually
replacing the pumps
since then we've not had any heavy rain
so we're not really sure of what the
outcome will be yet but i think the next
few days we could be
having a bit more rain so we'll see
perhaps thank you
okay thank you all those items will be
incorporated within the
uh notes of course with appropriate
actions
um taken so that they can be monitored
council person you want to come back
thank you so much um as we've got our
representative from england walter
even if he can't speak to us can he
actually confirm because
it's all very well and kind of um
counselor stepso to organize separate
meetings
but the whole idea of this platform is
that we're here
it's an open meeting the residents can
view this
recording and we need to have answers to
this
it is hoped that this is alleviating the
problem
but is it going to fix it and that's
what i want to know thank you
and i think that's a really good point i
mean it's refreshing to know that an
awful lot of points have been raised
are being addressed but they do need to
be fed back to the central
uh messaging system so that uh the wider
floor club forum members are aware of
what's going on because there's clearly
a lot of good work
that is going on but uh i think that's a
quite well made thank you very much
indeed
um now we've got 10 minutes or so
left um if we run to time um
what i'm keen to do is pick up on any um
points
that mark lloyd has made in the chat
because he hasn't been able to connect
sonya or jeffrey you're able to run us
through those points
happy to do so chairman um in in terms
of the
in terms of the uh the last uh the last
item
uh uh mark lloyd has suggested that um
any further issues that arise from
today's meeting
can be emailed to him and he will action
them for investigations
um and then he had some updates on the
anglian water items on the notes in the
last meeting if you want me to go
through those
chairmen would you mind
sure um so he says that on page seven
relating to fermi fermi draily
he contacted sanctuary housing after and
after the attendance which deemed this
was a non-anglian water issue
they were very reluctant to attend and
complete green and watercolor
watercourse clearance until the threat
of flooding to residents was clearly
explained
um and he says i can confirm they have
attended and completed the maintenance
required
although i have stressed that this needs
a preventative maintenance schedule
for works to be carried out
unfortunately this is something that
angling water cannot enforce
so can those not speaking go on mutes
please because there's a bit of
background noise
thank you uh and then on page eight
corn hill avenue anglian water
previously attended
and all surrounding angular water
southwest assets were all jetted and
cctv'ed with no issues found
we're hope we're happy for the developer
to request a section 106 fire angle and
water developer services
in order to connect onto our
angular water main to try and remedy
flooding but this will need to be
applied for via the developer
and then page four grove road rayleigh
uh pump internals were replaced around
2016 to enable more efficiency
this issue is currently on the list to
be looked at for hydraulic modelling
to ascertain if the root cause is our
network
or pumping station due to the pandemic
non-emergency works at angling water are
currently on hold
which has hampered investigations uh
that's it chairman
thank you very much indeed son yeah
councilman first you've got your hand up
sorry chairman i'm i'm persistent if
nothing counts
um as um dave chapman
kindly referred to organizing a site
visit
um perhaps we could hold down um our
mark lloyd to actually come along to
that site visit
only the ditch does impact on the
pumping station so it is one of the same
sort of
issue if that's possible and perhaps he
could answer that now
he's not sure he's got an audio linked
to us but uh
oh yeah he said he's very happy to
attend psychosis lovely thank you very
much mark
okay um right council award you've got
your hand up
yeah sorry i'm muting yeah um
it's just basically on the uh anglia
uh very poor let me see if i can get
this back up again because it's quite
difficult
actually all right just bear with me
we're getting the last
few minutes yeah it's the pumping
station
um literally uh i know that i've been
questioned
uh mark francois just asked me what the
progress and he wanted a time
actually when this was going to be
completed
maybe um again
if mark can come back and give an answer
he wanted something
definitive because of the issues that
are going on down there
and they have caused major problems
which obviously mark is aware of
because he put that in the chat at 12
40. so
um there's a time uh we we need us you
know a rag on this one if we
if we may thank you absolutely thank you
for that councillor cheryl rowe
thank you chairman um i just want to
speak towards the end of the close of
the meeting
if that's okay chairman so if you want
to finish off then i will just speak
before we close
right um what i would like to do is just
you know the most important thing for me
was certainly picking up on past issues
um certainly picking up on questions
from members of the public
and now i would like to have a quick run
round from any councillors where
i don't really want to repeat of any of
the past issues but is there anything
fresh
that any member on this group feels
needs to be raised that hasn't come up
in previous discussions
council ahoy thank you um
it was mentioned by jeff
very briefly um under the whole bridge
um section of his report um it actually
comes under roareth
i believe or partly rayleigh but it is
watery lane um
he used the terms the usual flooding uh
most people who live in locally don't
think it is
the usual flooding the flooding of all
tree lanes
has become a much more frequent
although temporary event in the past
it's flooded and stayed bloody for a
long time
now it appears to be flooding and then
clearing relatively quickly maybe in a
day
um there is suspicions that i've
mentioned it's davey wilson home it may
be to do with the way the
the suds is working on the site at the
moment or the way that the pond at the
bottom is
is draining immediately into the brook
along the side of watery lane
and i just want that um added to the
agenda on the permanent base if
not an apartment until it's sorted out
or or we get some clarity over what's
happening
if that's possible please chairman yeah
certainly i mean i think that anything
which is
impacting to make watery lane worse than
as the name implies a watery lane
um certainly we ought to uh be on top of
that
uh because we shouldn't be doing things
that exacerbate the problem
um trying to minimize it should be the
objective i think we agreed we'd be
there councillor thank you vice versa he
does kind of counselor standings
but i get the complaints because people
drive through it from holbridge
um the other thing was just very briefly
on manion's
the millions lane development which is
the land between la road and windermere
avenue
um i understand that um
andy and walter were being invited to
visit the site but i don't know if they
have
it's it's probably best if we can make
sure that's also
i know it's been raised and mentioned
but can we leave it on the agenda we
have to get it sorted out
quick quicker than that but i would
maybe liaise with mark lloyd outside the
meeting
on this because it needs a survey done
which counts three and walt mentioned
thank you okay lovely thank you
councillor stanley
thank you chairman uh just a couple of
pointers uh
and i do apologize that i got one place
mixed up with the other
um as i was saying about the ditch it
would be nice if we
if the ditch was cleared in london road
to hold the water rather than
uh let it uh spill over onto the road
which is uh esses county council's
responsibility um we've had part of the
ditch uh
cleared by by um rdc which i'm very
pleased about as which you could see
yourselves
but it's down to essex county council
also
uh the pumping station at the fair glen
when we did have the flood
on january the 14th um the water was
coming off of the
the new park if you like the the new
park was being built there um and
when the pump started um overfilled the
if you like the reservoir that's uh
further out by the railway line
which then went into the chichester
brook which then headed up into the raw
riff and thereby
raised the level in there i asked the
question
was the gates open for flood water to
get
out at battles bridge
um as far as i'm aware they weren't open
and that's what caused the flooding uh
to
rif at the bottom there um so i would
ask that question to the environment
agency or
whoever that may be um
there i'm i am as a as a
mark as i just got an email from marcus
saying that he is
trying to arrange this meeting with with
the relevant uh
organizations um so that's about all i
can do at the moment thank you okay all
right well that will be recorded as a
point that will there'll be an action
against to deal with the points that you
raise
um councillor weston hi thanks chairman
as i said
previously i am going to be having a
meeting with kevin bentley regarding
um walter lane i'm also in contact with
um brian martin carter and he's asked me
a question which i will be emailing
um mark lloyd about to do with the
pumping station from ferry road near
crouch near river crouch by plenty
gardens to the pumping station lower
road
and the development amelia's lane so i
will be asking or sending an email to
mark lloyd and i will keep councillor
michael hoy
and stuart wilson in holbrook um in
touch thank you okay
thank you very much council award
yeah thank you chairman it's just
quickly if i can ask jeff stacey
if he can make sure he does contact
andrew white
and gets a a get together because he's
one of the experts
from outside um with mark lloyd and
possibly dave chapman and roger webster
because you know there are issues that i
think are a multi-uh
authority that maybe he can uh
advise him okay last few comments before
i
bring this to a close make my final
comments but jeff
uh yes it was just just a reply to that
um
i was in touch with uh with
uh mr uh andrew waite isn't it
um and yeah we will be picking up on
that
um when we uh contacted each other it
was
clear this wasn't the right form and for
him to go into the the sort of level of
detail that he needs to do
and it would be better to do that as a
separate meeting so we will be picking
up on that
okay uh council williams yeah thank you
chairman um
i know a bit of a difficult start but
all in all i think it was a very
productive meeting thank you very much
uh but not wishing to labor but labour
the point i would like
um i would like to ask the councillors
county councillors to to to show our
displeasure
for essence county council highways for
not attending thank you
now sir williams thank you very much
indeed uh and people will get used to
the fact my style is very much
identify a problem decide whether you're
going to do something about
it and then action what you are going to
do about it
you know that's the way we're going to
move this forward in the future i'm
afraid
most excellent thank you thank you and
finally to you councillor before i wrap
up with a few closing comments
thank you chairman and with this i wear
my governance hat
so um can we please ascertain
obviously for obvious reasons we hadn't
had a meeting for 14 months
and that's understandable with the
situation we were in however this is an
extremely important meeting to our
residents
especially those are going through the
flooding situation so
can you please tell me chairman your
stance on how often you think you're
gonna have these meetings
and i assume that it won't be before
we're back in a
building of some sort where it can be
public
and we can we please please make sure
that residents are allowed to attend
these meetings
we've seen these in the past that they
are attended quite well
and people are just going to get
frustrated and quite frankly
i was almost flooded back in 2012 and
it's not a nice feeling
so i think those those people that do
have issues need to have
uh their voice um heard in in these kind
of meetings that's what they're for
thank you chairman absolutely right
councillor that feeds nicely into
my closing comments um in the sense that
flooding really if you're affected by
flooding
is every bit as bad as fire or other
hazards that
can occur and certainly
we do take this very seriously and we
should take it very seriously but
as an authority we have no statutory
responsibility
on flooding but i do believe that we do
have a responsibility to our residents
to ensure we engage with the
appropriate partners and certainly i
would like to
pay particular thanks to dave chapman
and roger webster
who have been able to join us uh
virtually on this meeting
and also thank mark lloyd who went
through a number of i.t
difficulties but at least was able to
respond uh on
on the chat function um so yes this is a
key
issue but moving forward look
you know i said at the start this isn't
ideal
virtual meetings will never be a
replacement for
those physical meetings where we can
truly engage
which is why i would like a meeting
autumn
and by autumn i mean sort of
september-ish that's that's what i'm
working to
and and it's to be hope that we can get
back into a physical meeting place
because
i welcome the opportunity to engage with
members of our public who care about
this this issue in exactly the same way
that we do
um i would um encourage
shall i say and i think i'm using the
word encourage but you'll know from my
earlier comments
that all partner agencies attend the
meeting as well
because you know i believe that
you should um i think a point was made
earlier
that meetings that go on between
councillors
should be somehow captured
so that that's fed into the system so
that the action plan can be updated
because there should really be the issue
action being taken
by officer councillor or whoever
and then some feedback so that we can
actually have a
public document which actually shows
what action
is is being taken and
i have to say with some skepticism
you know really we don't want
looking into we really want to looking
into
is it an issue and resolution uh
that is really what we we need to move
towards and
you know in all fairness some of these
things have been drifting on for a while
um and we need to understand it is not
good enough and i do
do pick out the caglushan pub why should
they look out every time it gets a
cloudy day why should they be looking
out the window
worrying as to whether or not they're
going to be funny while we go through
the bureaucratic process of deciding if
there's funding or whether we put it off
or can we find a solution
and i just use that as an example but it
applies to a number of these issues
where especially if premises are going
to be flooded
we should do better
the other thing i think is would be
helpful because i think that there
should
actually should be some member visits to
some of these sites
so that members are more aware of
the actual site location so i think uh
perhaps that's a possibility certainly
for
the ward councillors so i think we ought
to consider uh how we can engage
um and and get some member visits
really in conclusion i would certainly
like to
particularly thank members of the public
that
are looking at this uh through the
council's youtube channel
i want to make a personal apology that
it's not been possible today
for you to engage uh i was on a pretty
close uh
limit yesterday to decide whether or not
we
totally postponed this meeting until we
could have better engagement
i made the decision uh when i found out
that it wasn't going to be possible to
have direct engagement
that it should still go ahead i would
like to echo councillor williams
um views that i think it has actually
been a most productive meeting
uh in terms of pulling these issues
together
but rest assured um under my leadership
uh we will be uh dealing with this in a
business like fashion
uh we will be logging the points that
have been made today
the great fortune of a virtual meeting
is that uh it can be
re-heard re-looked at so that we make
sure that we capture all of all the
points we have superb officers
that will have been making robust notes
and
we come back together in an environment
in september
where i hope a number of the points have
been addressed so
can i thank everyone that's visited
today
very much and i thank members that have
taken part
very much officers thank you and with
that i will close the